優秀な人材の定義っていうのを明確にし
たらいいと思うんだよね人間力のある人
物事を成し遂げてく人っていうのがどの
会社でも活躍する人材だと思いますけどね
青木哲の人生経営哲学100回聞いたら
豊かになる
話今回はですね中小企業において優秀な
人材というのをどのようにして集めれば
良いのかということについてお聞かせ
いただけますでしょうか
難しいテーマだね私教えてもらえたいよ逆
にまただ1つ明確に言えることは自社に
とって優秀とは何を意味するのかという
その優秀な人材の定義っていうのを明確に
したらいいと思うんだよねだからま
シンプルに言うとその会社で最も活躍して
いる人たちまこれコンピテンシーモデルっ
てよく言うんですけどねその人たちが持っ
てる共通校あコンピテンシですよねそう
いうものをきちっと抽出をして例えば営業
分野で活躍している人たちの特徴ってどう
いうものなのかから管理部門で活躍してる
人たちはどういう特徴があるのかま商品
開発企画だとかねそれはどういう特徴が
あるのか論理的思考力があるこれも違い
なくね私はそういうなんだろう高望みをし
ても抽象概念の中で例えばハーバード大学
を出てる人を採用したいとかって考える人
いるかもしれないけどハーバード大学出
てる人が必ずしもね本社ににとってねま
うちで言うとうちの会社で活躍できるか
どうかって分からないよねだからその会社
の中で活躍できるやっぱりこう人材の能力
要件を明確にした上でじゃあその人たちは
どういうところにいるんだろう
かあの魚をね釣るということを考えた時に
どこにそういう魚はいるのかと例えば川の
海へのこう出口とちょうど交わってるよう
なところって割とこうなんだろう魚が
集まってくる場所だとかま色々あるじゃ
ないですかだ例えば体育会系の人材で
メンタルがすごく強い人材だったらこう
いうところにいるだろうとかまそういう
とこでまアチーブメントって
インターンシップで学生が選ぶ
インターンシップでま3年連続日本一に
なったんだけどそういうような
インターンシップを企画して学生に無料で
ねそのインターンシップ体験してもらって
その中から行動観察してさっき言ったよう
なな能力要件を持ってる人間を採用すると
そんなことをやってき
たりあとはやっぱり社員の紹介なんだろう
仕事っていうものに対する定義とそれから
僕一番大事にしてる能力ってその自分より
優れた人と共に働く能力なんですよだから
自分以下の人とは誰でも働けるけれど自分
より優れた人と一緒に力合わせ
るっていうことはやっぱりね人柄が良く
ないとね難しいだから必ずしも論理的思考
だけではなくて人柄誠実さだとか優しさだ
とかいろんな要素があるんだけどそういう
ものを私はすごく大事にしながらいろんな
こう例えば食事会のところに行ってききを
見たりそれからいろんなそういうなん
だろうなあのプログラムを設計して行動
観察をしたりだからま中小企業の場合は
多分アルバイトをまず1回ねアルバイトで
働いてもらってその中で使えそうな人を
口説いて正社員するとかそういうのはいい
かもしれないよねうんまできる限り学生の
いる場所に足を運んで触れて触れ合いを
っぱり作っていきながらそういう説明会と
か色々ありますからそんな中で縁を作って
採用するのが大事なんじゃないかなあとは
社員からの紹介うんあとはそういう企画
そんな風なことでえチャレンジしてみると
良いと思いますよありがとうございますま
アチーブメントにとっての逆に言うと優秀
な人材の定義ってどういう人材になるん
ですかあこれシンプルだよね会社の企業
理念に対しての共感がまずあ
るってことだよねうん我がは選択理論を元
にした高品質の人材教育を通して顧客の
成果の想像に貢献し全社員の物心両面の
幸福の追求とま社会の平和と繁栄に寄与
するこれを我々は上質の追求ということで
理念としてずっと37年追究してきてるん
だけどこの理念への共感というものがまず
あのすごく大事な理念共感型採用なので
あとはやっぱり責任化がある物事を
成し遂げるま一般的な人材要件ですから
あの私は若い時からプロの営業の世界に
入って結果を出してきたけど学校歴は
なかったけど論理的思考あったと思うん
ですよそして逆算をしてどうしたらそれが
成し遂げられるのかというやっぱ知恵も出
たし人の力も借りられたしともかく効果的
に働くことのできる能力を僕は有していた
と思うんだよねうちの社員を見ても結局は
そういうまあなんだろう人間力のある人
物事を成し遂げてく人っていうのがま結局
どの会社でも活躍する人材だと思います
けどねだうちの会社だから成功してるの
かって言うとおそらくよその会社に行って
も成功する人なんだと思うんですよだけど
縁があってまアチーブメントに入ってきて
くれただ僕はできる限りこの選択を正解に
できるように私にできることってどんな
ことなのかと思ってま真剣に誠実に社員と
は接しそしてま物心両面の豊かな人生を
与えられるそういう経営を目指してきたと
いうことです
ありがとうございます理念への共感性って
言ってしまうとなんか突然そのま優秀な
人材っていうのがこう少なくなっちゃう気
がしていてなんかその理念共感っっていう
のを重視すべきなのかまずは一緒に働いて
みないと分からないなのかなんかどっちな
んです
[音楽]
かうん微妙それ両方ともなんか一理あるん
だよねま確かにそうだよねあのまこれだけ
長くも丸10年以上相採用アチーブメント
もやってきたま僕が深層作用に踏み切った
の47歳の時なんで社員がまだ25名の時
ですからそこからチャレンジをしてきて
まあこの20年で4億7000万直接費用
だけで使っているのでまあ正直思考錯誤の
連続でしたうんただ1つ言えることはその
時最善と思うことを一生懸命大事にしてき
たんだ
けどうんどうなんだろうなやっぱりでも僕
は採用って恋愛じゃなくて結婚だと思っ
てるんですよある経営者が僕に青木さん
そんなね
堅苦しく気真面目に考える必要ないよって
はっきり言ってやらせてみないとわかん
ないんだからもっとデコレーションもっと
綺麗にうまく作ってとりあえずガンガン
入れて
もうやめてくやつはやめてくやつでいい
じゃないかとねそれはもうお互い様なんだ
からて恋愛みたいなもんだよって
おっしゃった人がいるんだけど僕はそうは
思わないんだよ
ねだから悪いとこいっぱい見せちゃうし
うちはまだ至らなくてこんな状態ですとま
今うちはね経団連にも入ったしね入れて
いただけたりまあ当初の議員企業にもなっ
たりに本当におかげ様であのま今働きが
アバドでも9年連続ベストカンパニーに
入ってるぐらいだから今は客観的にもいい
会社だと胸を晴れる状態だと思いますただ
私の理想はもっと高いんだけどねこんな
もんじゃないんですようんただ社会から
見るといい会社だと思われてると思います
僕はでも理想が高いここがポイントなのよ
ねうちよりもはるかに低いレベルで低賃金
でき使ってそれで不足言ってる経営者も
いっぱいいるからねどっちがいいか分から
ないけどやっぱり本音本心本気で僕はこう
いう事業をやりたいと思っているとこう
いうこと成し遂げたいんだと一緒に力
合わせてやってかないかと今給料も低く
そんなに高くは払えないかもしれないと
うちはまだまだねこういうレベルだと社員
もこんだけしかいないとだけど絶対僕は
将来必ずねみんなを豊かに
できる根拠のない自信はあるんだみたいな
さそういう気合いま気合いじゃ飯食えない
んだけどさでもそんな気持ちは僕は昔から
持ってたと思うんだよね最初からうちが今
のレベルじゃないもん正直厳しい状態だっ
てあったんだもんでも今うちの幹部になっ
てる子たちはそういう中でもま社長の志し
に
しなんかこの仕事いい仕事だよねみたいな
なんだろうなそうやってみんなの善意に
支えられてなんか今があるんじゃないかな
と思うんだよねだからやっぱり本音本心で
僕はやっぱりあえて言うとやっぱり結婚と
同じぐらいの基準でやっぱり人を選びたい
イコール理念共感のタイプですね私はうん
だそれどっちが正解なのかやってみわかん
ないようんそんな
[音楽]
感じまぶっちゃけ言うとね経営者の器以上
の人は集められませんはいだからもう愛情
があるかどうかよぶっちゃけ経営者に俺
はっきりあると思う可愛いもん社員可愛い
うんいっつも考えてるどうしたらもっと
物資共に豊かにできるかで事実税引語利益
の3割社員に決算で払ってるしなもう
2006年からずっとやってんだからうん
だから色々綺麗語と言ったって低賃金で呼
使う発想を持ってる会社はこれから厳しい
と思うよだから働く人の立場に立って考え
るってことなんじゃないのあとは持った話
をしないで等身台で一生懸命働いて自分が
一生懸命ね価値を作り出しして社員を1日
も早く豊かにしてあげようとそういう真心
で働くってことなんじゃないかなもうそれ
しか言えないな俺はうん以上っって感じか
なよろしいでしょうかはいはいありがとう
ございますうんえ是非ねまたコメントを
よろしくお願いしますそしてチャンネル
登録もお忘れなく